you don't have to travel around the
globe for a solution to the brexit
dilemma it can be found right at
Europe's doorstep hop on a plane to
Norway and here in a country that has a
rejected you membership twice but
together with states like Iceland or
Liechtenstein they have negotiated an
agreement with the European Union that
gives them full access to the single
market and there you have it the
Norwegian model but it's Norway really
the off-the-shelf solution that Britain
is looking for we head out to the
countryside to find out what drives this
skin an avian powerhouse
Svein who sells famous Norwegian king
crabs and just like the economy as a
whole he relies heavily on the European
Union more than 80% of Norway's exports
are to EU Member States and one of the
key advantages are shared standards I
don't need to spend a long time
explaining to my European customer what
I'm meaning because they are looking for
exactly the same what I'm presenting if
I go somewhere else in the world
Churchill is historically wise there are
some some other issues so European
market EU is a very important market of
breath because they are close and you're
the same but there's a prize for
Norway's access to the EU market which
Britain might be unwilling to pay the
free movement of labour Norway's
government however sees it as a huge
benefit actually no ways one of the
countries having the largest portion of
foreign labor from the EI EU countries
in Norway and we depend upon the work is
a labor force from from other European
countries so this is actually important
for us and there are other potential
perks with its arrangement Norway is not
part of the customs union that means it
can unlike EU Member States strike its
own trade deals something that breaks
the tears argued is one of the biggest
benefits of brexit but the agreement
costs Norway a lot of money 391 million
euros go to the EU each year there is
almost as much per head as Great Britain
pays today only the UK gets full
membership in return Britain in the EU
is currently a lawmaker Norway is a law
taker a law taker that receives on
average 5 new EU directives per day
which must be implemented no questions
researcher yon ethic in time keeps a
folder of all the legal directors from
Brussels he calls it the EU Bible we
have implemented more than 10,000 rules
and regulations from from Brussels as a
voter
I would like my Prime Minister my
Minister of Transport whatever to sit in
Brussels
with all the others and decide my future
we have given it all away
that's why Britain could never join such
an agreement as we have despite the
downsides a large majority of Norwegians
love the deal and at least for the
transition period after brexit Norway
might be the right blueprint for Great
Britain